anyway we turned from that shocking
story to something much more uplifting
now Carlos Gavita
is a resident from Jupiter Florida he
says he was blocked by community
management from flying a political flag
supporting Donald Trump came up with a
clever idea
he decided after well he took down that
poster that he would put his boat and
wrap it in Trump and get the general
restriction on flags and get around it
that was accompanied by an inspiring
patriotic display this weekend and by
the way more defiance people have said
well this is our level of risk that
we're comfortable with and yet a boat of
parade hundreds of boaters reported to
have set sail from Jupiter Inlet they
went down the intercoastal they sailed
all the way to Palm Beach Florida it was
more on that is that resident himself
Carlos thanks for joining us how are you
sir
hey Sean how are you thanks for having
me on thank you for being here all right
so yeah help walk us through this so you
had a Trump sign up or right yeah it's
against the rules
yeah I had a Trump flag you know the
Trump flag and you know at Adams Cove I
didn't know that you couldn't really
have a political flag so obviously I
complied took it down but I really
wanted to support the president so I
looked into a little further and I
documented the boat with the US Coast
Guard named Trump and within four days I
had my buddy at Atlas signs make me a
rap and I was off to the races and that
was me bringing it home there at
Admiral's Cove playing the national
anthem they did a great job all right
tell us about all these boats I have a
lot of sympathy this is my take on it
and I'm I would urge people to be I
watch this thing in New York especially
for the elderly those with compromised
immune systems and underlying conditions
if you get this virus you're in trouble
there's no doubt about it so I would
urge people but they're people are
decided they're gonna they're gonna get
out they're sick of being put up I want
people to do it safely
nothing safer than being on the water I
guess right as long
we I mean we all we had limits on the
boats that we could have on there and
you know we had eight six seven people
depending on how large your boat was but
uh it was it was an awesome
you know we had a boat picks you know
far the helicopter and it was actually
he said after at 1981 he's been flying
he's never seen eight miles worth of
voters over 3,000 votes it was amazing
I'm well I will say this you know what I
believe in free speech good for you a
very creative way and we want our fruit
that we're going to open the country
let's open it safely let's protect our
elderly